das sind wirklich katastrophale
neuigkeiten bei facebook mussten zwei
jackpots die mit künstlicher
intelligenz ki ausgestattet waren
getötet werden also genau das was ihnen
macht forderte marx wasserburg ablehnt
musste hier gesehen
die beiden programme entwickelten ein
eigenleben das nicht mehr kontrolliert
werden konnte
wenn sie also kurz vor der tat die
katastrophe und der gefahr dass
irgendein programm sehr schnell sehr
mächtig wird und die welt unter york
jetzt entwicklung science fiction
herzlich willkommen genau das ist der
super-gau der künstlichen intelligenz
ki vor dem lask warnt eine ki macht sich
selbstständig und kann nicht mehr von
menschen kontrolliert werden schritt 1
sie entwickelt eine sprache die vom
menschen nicht mehr verstanden wird
genau das haben jetzt die facebook chat
bottrop und alice gemacht grund war ein
versäumnis der programmierer und
programmiererin sie hatten englisch
nicht als verpflichtende sprache
festgelegt und so entwickelten die
jackpot ein eigenleben und eine eigene
geheimsprache die entwickler waren nicht
mehr in der lage zu kontrollieren
worüber die beiden boards sprachen war
hatte die kommunikation noch etwas mit
englisch zu tun aber in deutlich ab
gewandter form kostprobe gefällig box
everything as antwort von alisa wolf
airports sumitomo mitsui zu lean die
mehrmalige wiederholung von wörtern und
wachs teilen scheint etwas mit fällen
zu tun zu haben
aber zu mehr erkenntnissen sind die
entwickler und entwicklerin mich
willkommen die sache wurde ihm zu heiß
und sie zogen den stecker sie töteten
alice und bob denn auch den kolleginnen
und kollegen ist klar welche immense
gefahr hinter ki steckt nicht umfangs
waren stephen hawking und ihnen macht
und viele andere vor einer größeren
gefahr als der durch atombomben passen
wir hier nicht wie die schoßhunde auf
dann ist die welt plötzlich in den
händen einer und mit abstand
überlegenen spezies und genau das
fordern wir ihnen massaker gegen seine
eigenen interessen er will eine
staatliche kontrolle gesetze und so
weiter denn in diesem fall hat das team
den stecker rechtzeitig selbst gezogen
sie wurden einfach nicht mehr worüber
die künstlichen intelligenten
miteinander gesprochen haben aber
was wenn wir nicht getan hätten genau
für diesen fall fordern kritiker
kontrolle und zwar bevor etwas passiert
mark zuckerberg ist strikt dagegen kein
wunder er muss gegenüber google
aufholen
hier wird ki schon im alltag eingesetzt
und empfiehlt zum beispiel dieses video
auf youtube was und wie sind wohl wird
darüber gibt es kaum kontrolle und auch
hier sind schon die gefahren immens wenn
wir zum beispiel die auswirkung von hate
speech auf facebook sehen ganze wahlen
könnte ki so steuern und wir merken es
noch nicht mal es wird und bleibt also
spannend wir bleiben hier am ball und
informieren euch über die neuesten
entwicklungen wenn ihr kein video zum
thema und zu anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergesst nicht den auf die
glocke hier geht es weiter mit dem
streit zwischen max wacker baronin mark
streit um künstliche intelligenz da
geht es hoch her
und es gibt noch mehr hintergrund zum
thema wenn es euch interessiert
unbedingt drauf klicken und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran